g'day there living on acreage can bring
extra work and responsibilities but a
rural lifestyle can also bring much joy
and satisfaction
likewise keeping stock can be very
rewarding but at times potentially
frustrating to you and your neighbours
livestock often don't acknowledge fences
and live by their own rules and if not
managed properly can be a threat to
themselves and local farms
so understandably they're governed by
regulations to keep your animals and
local farming industry safe here are
some of the main ones
you're responsible for making sure your
animals have adequate food and water are
handled properly protected from extreme
weather conditions and otherwise healthy
before purchasing any stock you must get
a property identification code or pick
any new south wales property carrying
livestock is required by law to have a
pick yep even if it's just one horse or
a potty car you must have a pick
before loading and transporting stock
you must ensure they're correctly
identified with a national livestock
identification system that is nlis tag
or device all movements must be recorded
on the nlis database your local land
services office can help you get the
correct paperwork to help protect our ag
industry and keep markets open you need
to notify us local land services if you
suspect or are aware of a range of
livestock diseases as a livestock owner
you also should have a solid
understanding of pasture management and
feeding programs during drought there's
some great information on the local land
services and department of primary
industries websites
until next time cheers
[Music]
you